mesdames et messieurs nous poursuivons
ce matin nos travaux sur la thématique
santé des femmes au travail avec nos
quatre rapporteurs Laurence Cohen Annick
Jacquemet Marie-Pierre Richer et
Laurence Rossignol ce matin avec nous
lors de notre table ronde du 23 mars
dernier nous avons été présentés nous
ont été présentés pardon deux études
récentes particulièrement intéressantes
une étude de la NAC qui pointe une
sous-estimation des risques
professionnels auxquelles les femmes
sont exposées tout particulièrement dans
les secteurs après dominance féminines
ainsi qu'une étude de la DARES qui a mis
en évidence une exposition différenciée
des femmes et des hommes au risque
professionnel qui s'expliquent bien sûr
par des métiers souvent différents mais
s'observent aussi au sein des mêmes
professions sur la base de ces constats
nous assemblés indispensables
d'organiser des tables rondes sectoriels
consacré au secteur d'activité au sein
desquelles les femmes sont majoritaires
et qui ont été mis en avant par les
études
précités
notre première table ronde est consacrée
au secteur dit du Caire qui regroupe
tous les métiers du soin de l'aide à
domicile du service à la personne du
lien les femmes représentent selon le
périmètre retenu 70 à 90% des
travailleurs de ce secteur selon une
étude de l'institut odoxal réalisé par
la mutuelle nationale des hospitaliers
et le Figaro publié le 8 mars dernier
les femmes professionnelles de santé et
tout particulièrement les infirmières et
aides-soignantes sont plus sujettes aux
problèmes de santé que la population
générale leur travail a des conséquences
directes sur leur santé physique comme
mentale ainsi les trois quarts des
Hospitalières déclarent que leur travail
implique une pénibilité physique
importante soit 7 points de plus que
leurs collègues masculins et 30 points
de plus que pour l'ensemble des actifs
80% d'entre elles déclarent que leur
travail génère un stress très important
soit 30 points de plus que le reste des
actifs en emploi outre des risques
physiques les salariés du secteur du
Caire sont confrontés à des exigences
émotionnelles fortes du fait de leur
contact avec le public à des contraintes
organiques organisationnels importantes
de fortes amplitude horaire des horaires
morcelés des week-ends
tous ces risques physiques et psychiques
exigent des mesures de prévention
adaptées qui ne semblent pas pleinement
définies ni mises en oeuvre aujourd'hui
et ce sera un point central de nos
échanges de ce matin dans l'optique de
formuler évidemment des préconisations
opérationnelles pour approfondir ces
différents sujets nous accueillons outre
les rapporteurs Robin mort directeur des
affaires publiques de la Mutuelle
Nationale des hospitaliers qui à
l'origine de la récente étude odoxa sur
les conditions de travail des femmes
professionnelles de santé que j'ai
précédemment cité Catherine corne nibert
directrice générale de l'association
soins aux professionnels de santé qui
est avec nous en visio-conférence
bonjour madame
Nathalie canieux chargé de mission à la
CFDT ancienne membre du 16e et
rapporteur de la vie du 16e intitulé Le
travail à domicile auprès des personnes
vulnérables des métiers du lien elle va
nous rejoindre j'imagine dans quelques
instants et probablement bloqué à la
sécurité du Sénat et Béatrice barte avec
nous ce matin également maître de
conférence en
ergonomie experts et rapporteur de
landeces auteur de travaux sur les temps
de travail atypiques et notamment le
travail de nuit fréquent dans les
hôpitaux et les EHPAD et dont on connaît
désormais l'impact sur le risque de
développer un cancer du sein par exemple
ce cancer a d'ailleurs été très
récemment reconnu comme maladie
professionnelle dans le cas d'une
infirmière qui avait travaillé de nuit à
l'hôpital durant 28 années
bienvenue à toutes et tous donc je
laisse sans plus tarder la parole à
Robin more pour la MNH qui pourra
approfondir pour nous les résultats de
l'étude menées auprès des professionnels
de santé sur leurs conditions de travail
et sur l'incidence de ces conditions sur
leur état de santé à vous monsieur
merci madame la Présidente donc madame
la Présidente Mesdames les rapporteurs
mesdames très heureux et de parmi vous
aujourd'hui merci pour cette invitation
et pour l'attention que vous avez pu
porter à notre étude mais plus
globalement pour la tension que vous
allez porter à la santé des femmes du
Caire enfin vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente en introduction elle
représente entre 70 et 90% des des
personnels qui prennent soin des
Françaises des Français au quotidien et
qui mécaniquement à travers leur
implication dans le service public de
santé
participe à la cohésion nationale et un
un sujet qui est un sujet de
préoccupation majeure de nos concitoyens
qui est l'accès à la santé et donc on
sait très bien des études le prouve et
on y reviendra que des professionnels de
santé en bonne santé prennent mieux en
charge leur patients l'inversé temps
exact également il est intéressant de
s'intéresser à leur état de santé alors
je vais rentrer un peu directement dans
le vif du sujet vous avez déjà
planté le décor oui l'état de santé des
femmes qui travaillent dans le secteur
de la santé ou plus largement dans le
secteur du Caire et préoccupant
et voir très préoccupant je pense que
préoccupant est encore un euphémisme
quand on regarde les indicateurs qu'on
peut ressortir des différentes études
dont on va être amené à parler alors moi
je vais accès mes propos sur une
population en particulier qui celles des
Hospitalières parce que la mutuelle que
je représente protège les agents du
service public hospitalier et donc
mécaniquement on a une visibilité
particulière sur cette population là et
donc mon propos ne traitera pas d'autres
populations comme les aides à domicile
ou là pour le coup j'ai pas de données à
vous partager et donc ça mériterait
peut-être d'être creusé avec des acteurs
des acteurs complémentaires
alors pour nous vous l'avez rappelé la
santé au travail vous avez rappelé
l'étude de la nacte et l'étude de la
DARES l'hôpital en réalité c'est un
miroir grossissant de la société sur les
difficultés de santé que peuvent
rencontrer les femmes au travail et sur
vous l'avez dit la sous-évaluation en
tout cas la manque de considération qui
peut y avoir au risque spécifique auquel
elles peuvent être exposées dans le
cadre de leur exercice professionnel
au-delà de ça si on a on note des
différences dans les études qu'on mène
sur l'état de santé entre les femmes
hospitalières et les femmes actives en
général il faut bien prendre en
considération qu'on a aussi des
inégalités de santé au sein même de la
population féminine à l'hôpital la
réalité de la santé d'une médecin n'est
pas la même que la réalité d'une femme
qui est aide-soignante ce n'est pas la
même que la réalité d'une femme qui est
infirmière qui est enfin pardon agent de
service hospitalier ou qui est agent
administrative et donc c'est ça avec
cette complexité là qui va falloir
regarder les choses et on va voir que
si des études scientifiques traitent du
sujet de la santé des médecins et même
si c'est encore parcellaire à ce stade
la santé de certaines professions comme
les aides soignants comme les agents de
service hospitaliers sont à peu près
complètement inexplorés par la recherche
scientifique et donc manque totalement
de données objectives sur leur état de
santé en y reviendra
alors vous avez cité l'Observatoire
qu'on a été amené à publier avec
l'Institut au doxa et et le Figaro
moi je vais revenir sur quelques
enseignements clés déjà deux
enseignements généraux qui concernent à
la fois les hospitalières et les
Hospitaliers quand on interroge les la
population hospitalière sur
leur appréhension de leur propre santé
avec le biais que pour présenter un
sondage mais en tout cas c'est une
interrogation qu'on leur a adressée
un quart des hospitaliers se déclare
être en mauvaise santé et quand on les
met en miroir avec la population active
c'est deux fois plus que la population
active quand on commence à un panel
représentatif d'actifs de nous dire dans
quel état de santé il se trouve ils sont
que 13% à nous dire qu'ils se sentent en
mauvaise santé contre 25% enfin 24 pour
les hospitaliers et quand on interroge
des populations plus spécifiques on voit
que le risque augmente la population
aide-soignante nous déclare être à un
tiers en mauvaise santé donc c'est
au-delà de la moyenne des Hospitaliers
donc vous voyez plus on descend je
parlais tout à l'heure des inégalités
socioprofessionnelles qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver à l'hôpital on le retrouve
dans les données quand on explore des
questions plus spécifiquement avec
certaines populations
ils sont plus de 70% à nous dire que
leur métier fatigant c'est 25% de plus
que la moyenne générale et là encore
quand on regarde les les différentes
professions et qu'on interroge la
population encore une fois
aide-soignante on n'est plus à 70% qui
nous disent que leur métier fatiguant
mais on approche les 90
et donc on voit bien que là on a une
réalité qui est différente et diverses
en fonction de la population interrogée
alors si on fait un zoom sur les
hospitalières
et qu'on les met en regard des actifs en
général puisque c'est le sujet qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui
vous l'avez dit 73 % des Hospitalières
qu'on a interrogé se déclare déclare que
leur travail à un impact négatif sur
leur état de santé c'est 36 points de
plus que les actifs en emploi en général
elles sont 82% à nous dire qu'elles sont
victimes où ont été victimes
d'incivilités d'agressivité de violences
au travail c'est deux fois plus que les
actifs en emploi en général donc on a
vraiment des indicateurs très clairs sur
le sujet et quand on les interroge
est-ce que l'impact de votre travail sur
votre santé vous amène à réfléchir sur
votre parcours professionnel elles sont
60% à nous dire que elles ont envisagé
de quitter leur travail à cause de
l'impact que ça sur leur santé et quand
on voit la réalité de la composition
démographique des professions de santé
composé très majoritairement d'effectifs
féminins et qu'on voit que on est à des
proportions de telles qu'elles sont plus
de la moitié à envisager de quitter leur
métier à cause de l'impact que qu'il a
sur leur santé on a des interrogations à
avoir quand on compare ces 20% de plus
avec les actifs en emploi en général
toutes populations confondues
alors moi je tiens enfin je vais pas
faire une longue liste une longue
litanie de chiffres mais je tiens à
votre disposition tous les chiffres de
l'Observatoire et les analyses qu'on
peut être amené à faire sur les
différentes questions qu'on a pu être
amenées à poser je vous les adresserai
si vous le souhaitez apost terrorisme
notre réunion
nous on a essayé de regarder finalement
c'est intéressant des sondages mais ça
présente un certain nombre de biais on a
essayé de creuser un petit peu ce que la
littérature scientifique pouvait nous
dire sur l'état de santé de cette
population là en partant du principe que
si elle déclarait être un mauvaise santé
il était possible on retrouve dans la
littérature scientifique des éléments
qui corroborer les constats qu'on était
amenés à faire via des sondages
alors là on a on a on a un peu étonné
enfin même grandement étonné donc c'est
on a missionné notre fondation
d'entreprise pour mener ses études
bibliographiques et en réalité il y a
quasiment aucune étude
sur la population professionnelle de
santé qui existe il y a quelques études
à l'international qui commence à dater
un petit peu que sur la population
féminine la propre en parler à la santé
des femmes de santé on a quelques études
notamment une étude à Taïwan sur la
question du cancer des médecins on a une
étude américaine sur la surexposition au
burn-out on a voilà quelques
publications mais en réalité rien de
bien étayé quand on compare à d'autres
populations exposées à des risques
particuliers
et ce qui nous fait ce qui nous nous
interroge c'est à dire que les
professionnels de santé sont toute la
journée en train de produire avec leur
équipe hospitalier universitaire des
études sur l'état de santé de
différentes populations et sur ces
populations là mon sèche un petit peu
alors les quelques études qui existent
corroborse qu'on peut noter dans les
dans les dans les observateurs qu'on a
amené à faire mais en réalité on
retrouve les mêmes problématiques
sociaux professionnels c'est que plus on
essaye de creuser certaines strates
professionnelles de l'hôpital moins on
trouve d'études il y a quelques études
sur la population médicale les internes
il y a quasiment aucune étude sur la
profession infirmière il n'y a
absolument aucune étude sur les
aides-soignantes et je vous parle même
pas des agences hospitalières enfin des
agents de service hospitalier etc
donc ça nous a amené à réfléchir sur le
sujet et à se dire qu'en fait
il fallait peut-être étayer et
accompagner la recherche sur ces sujets
et ce qui nous a amené dernièrement à
publier un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt commun entre notre fondation
et l'adresse
pour que des équipes de hospital ou
universitaires puissent croiser deux
bases de données l'INSEE et le snds pour
mener des études exploratoires sur un
certain nombre d'item dont la santé des
femmes de santé pour essayer de
détailler avec des données on va dire
scientifique à proprement parler avec la
réalité des chiffres que ce que de ce
que ce qui va pouvoir sortir de la base
snds notamment
on va essayer de sortir un petit peu
est-ce que les constats qu'on est amené
à faire dans les sondages et dans les
quelques études qui peuvent être
publiées soit spécifiquement sur
quelques professions de santé soit sur
la population générale sont cohérentes
avec ce qu'on peut constater vis-à-vis
d'une population spécifique qui est
celle de de la profession de santé et là
encore si jamais c'est revu
bibliographiques vous intéressent on
peut les mettre à votre disposition et
sont déjà été rendus publics et on peut
vous les adresser si vous le souhaitez
pour avoir un peu un état des lieux sur
quelques items ladictologie la santé
mentale ou encore la santé des femmes de
santé
les résultats de quelques études qu'on a
pu être amenées à constater
alors
maintenant qu'on a dit ça finalement on
est sur un tableau assez pessimiste ou
assez négatif
c'est dommage de commencer une journée
comme ça
mais qui pointe un élément c'est qu'en
fait le temps du constat est un peu
dépassé aujourd'hui et la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et comment on agit
efficacement pour améliorer la situation
nous récemment on a en train de produire
un ouvrage là que qui vous sera adressé
à l'été à peu près où on allait
interroger une douzaine de
professionnels les de santé avec la
diversité des métiers à l'hôpital pour
leur demander enfin voilà pour les
interroger donc c'est un cahier
d'interview que vous allez recevoir de
personnes qui vivent l'hôpital au
quotidien et et en réalité
leurs paroles que je relaie ici c'est de
nous dire que finalement tout ça on le
savait c'est peut-être pas étayé ça
mérite peut-être d'être précisé enfin on
y reviendra vous y reviendrait peut-être
tout à l'heure dans vos propos ça mérite
de des éléments complémentaires mais que
tout ça on le sait maintenant la
question c'est l'attente des
professionnels d'une vérité de d'action
véritable et d'une véritable politique
publique en réalité d'amélioration de
leur état de santé
et ça nous à la mutuelle vous avez dû le
recevoir il y a pas longtemps on a
produit quelques propositions sur le
sujet de la santé des professionnels de
santé vous avez peut-être dû le recevoir
il me semble la semaine dernière et si
jamais vous souhaitez qu'on vous l'aurez
adresse je vous adresse sans difficulté
on essaie de mettre sur la table
justement comment pourrait se structurer
cette politique de santé pour les
Hospitalières en tout cas pour la
population qui nous concerne
parce qu'on pourra pas compter
indéfiniment sur leur résilience
incroyable et
incontestable aujourd'hui on travaille
dans des conditions assez particulières
avec un faisceau de déterminant qui a
qui aboutit cette situation
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait finalement
nous ce qu'on constate c'est qu'il y a
une pluralité d'initiative qui sont déjà
en place en réalité quand on va fouiller
un peu à l'hôpital et qu'on essaye
d'interroger les Hospitaliers sur les
initiatives qui sont prises pour
améliorer la santé des professionnels il
y a déjà des initiatives l'hôpital est
pas muet sur le sujet la question
centrale qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
c'est qu'en réalité il n'y a pas de
priorité fixée sur les actions qu'il
faut mener c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont
les trois ou quatre sujets prioritaires
qu'il faut rémener sur la santé des
femmes hospitalières est-ce que c'est le
cancer du sein et l'utérus et du coup la
question du travail de nuit est-ce que
c'est la grossesse et l'incidence du
travail sur la grossesse est-ce que
c'est l'endométriose est-ce que c'est
des pathologies plus enfin partagées
entre les femmes et les hommes etc etc
est-ce que c'est la santé psychologique
bref la question c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
a besoin de savoir et d'avoir une
politique publique qui est tournée très
très clairement sur l'action sur quels
sont les quatre cinq priorités que vont
se fixer l'ensemble des acteurs pour
essayer d'arrêter la interdiction
d'énergie qu'on peut constater un peu
partout qui est tout le monde fait un
peu une initiative dans son coin et
qu'en réalité on n'a pas de direction
commune sur lesquelles l'assurance
maladie les complémentaires santé les
employeurs les partenaires sociaux les
pouvoirs publics orientent l'action pour
essayer d'analyser un état des lieux
mener des actions expérimentées et
analyser l'impact qu'on peut avoir
ça pour ça nous on appelle à ce que on
ne crée pas des nouveaux outils il
existe déjà des outils j'y reviendrai
pour terminer mon propos introductif
avant de qu'on puisse passer à la suite
de l'intention des interventions mais en
réalité il y a déjà des outils qui
existent à l'hôpital et qui peuvent être
utilisés au service de cette politique
de santé
nous globalement quand on regarde et
c'est l'objet de la documentation qu'on
vous a produit nous on appelle à ce qui
est 4 priorités qui soient fixé
la première c'est je reviens de la
recherche qui a eu un vrai forfait sur
la recherche non pas pour reconstatter
que les Hospitaliers vont mal mais pour
comprendre quelles sont les déterminants
sur lesquels on peut prioritairement
agir typiquement est-ce que le cancer du
sein on sait les fins des études
internationales nous démontre qu'il y a
un surrisque d'être diagnostiqué
tardivement pour les femmes les femmes
de santé est-ce que c'est corroboré par
de la recherche qui nous indiquent que
oui les femmes de santé sous consomment
les politiques de prévention de
l'assurance maladie en matière de
dépistage du cancer du sein à partir de
50 ans si oui comment on fait pour que
tous les acteurs adressent les éléments
sur le sujet donc ça c'est le premier
élément c'est la recherche le deuxième
vous en avez parlé le virage préventif
je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin que
la LSS tel qu'elle a été définie pour
2023 elle enclenche le virage préventif
il faut aller plus loin à travers une
vraie politique de prévention et des
dispositifs qui facilitent la prévention
au travail
et ça on a un vrai sujet de
complémentarité assurance maladie et
complémentaire santé sur le sujet
on a un troisième sujet qui est je vais
y revenir sur la santé des Hospitalières
à proprement parler et la quatrième
priorité pour nous qui est commune aux
hospitalières aux hospitaliers qui leur
santé psychologique
et là nous le constat c'est que on est
en surconsommation mais je pense que
Madame cornibert pour y revenir plus
précisément que moi parce que c'est un
sujet qu'elle regarde avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'attention
aujourd'hui nous en termes de
consommation de soi on note sur la santé
psychologique qu'on a une
surconsommation inexplosion de la
consultation fin des consultations
psychologues des hospitalisations en
psychiatrie etc sur la population qu'on
couvre versus la population générale
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut utiliser mais
finalement on peut utiliser déjà ce qui
existe on a parlé des campagnes de
dépistage aujourd'hui nous on
suit plus que
il puisse y avoir une sous-consommation
des campagnes de dépistage donc la
question du aller vers les
professionnels de santé et on parle
notamment des professionnels de nuit
est un vrai sujet comment on met en
place une action qui permet de
promouvoir les campagnes de dépistage du
cancer du sein du Conseil du col du
l'utérus etc vis-à-vis de population
pensait être surexposées à ce risque
vous avez les plans égalité famom
aujourd'hui qui sont en cours de
déploiement l'hôpital public qui peuvent
être de véritables outils dans lesquels
on peut traiter de la santé alors soit
par un prisme parcours professionnel
soit par un prisme de moments de vie
typiquement les plans égalité famom
peuvent traiter du sujet de la grossesse
du moment de la grossesse son impact sur
l'évolution professionnelle on peut très
très bien envisager qu'on puisse traiter
de la prévention santé de la femme
enceinte dans ces plans là au travail et
faire en sorte que le travail des femmes
de santé ne soit pas un obstacle alors
projet familial ou en tout cas à leur
santé est assez de leur enfant à naître
ce qui est un vrai sujet aujourd'hui
typiquement le même sujet sur
l'endométriose même sujet sur la
surveillance d'un cancer la question de
la prévention du maintien dans l'emploi
et du retour à l'emploi sont des sujets
qui peuvent être traités par le prisme
santé dans les plans égalité famom
et on a d'autres outils et je terminerai
par là par exemple le document unique
des risques professionnels d'évaluation
des risques professionnels dans les
établissements de santé qui aujourd'hui
encore malheureusement c'est pas le cas
partout mais beaucoup vécu comme un
document administratif peut être un vrai
outil dans lequel on peut avoir une
approche genrée des risques
professionnels objectiver les risques en
fonction du sexe et de la population
professionnelle qui exposée je pense que
on pourrait revenir au cours des débats
pour le coup il y a des établissements
qui sont saisis de ces deux plans des
établissements hospitaliers qui sont en
point de sur ces sujets et je pense
qu'il y a une maturité aujourd'hui en
tout cas il y a une prise de conscience
que ces documents au-delà d'être
document obligatoire doivent être des
documents mis au service de
l'amélioration de l'état de santé et
plus globalement de la prévention des
risques professionnels auxquels sont
exposées les femmes de santé voilà moi
je suis à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions après les
différentes interventions et puis je
vous remercie une nouvelle fois de
l'attention que vous pouvez porter à ce
sujet
merci Monsieur more donc on va tout de
suite passer la parole à Madame
Catherine cornibert qui est directrice
générale de l'association soins aux
professionnels de santé et
d'ores et déjà merci pour tous les
l'exposé que vous avez pu nous faire
puisque on le voit il y a beaucoup de
travail à faire sur la santé des femmes
au travail à vous madame qui est en
visio avec nous bonjour madame la
Présidente bonjour
mesdames mesdames les rapporteurs désolé
de pas être parmi vous mais en tout cas
le curieux comme étant une femme
également de santé j'avais été élu femme
de santé 2021 donc au combien le sujet
est pour moi très important au regard
également de du poste que j'occupe ce
que je suis directrice générale de
l'association
SPS soit un professionnel de la santé et
j'ai confondé avec d'autres acteurs de
santé
cette association qui est une
association loi 1901 lucratif reconnu
d'intérêt général en 2015 et cette
association aînée effectivement d'un
petit groupe
d'acteurs de santé qui voulait s'occuper
déjà de la santé des soignants et des
soignants et qui à l'époque était un
sujet et ça l'est toujours un peu tabou
donc il fallait pas parler et dont nous
avait dit que c'était honteux établi et
ça serait abîmé l'image de la profession
alors maintenant ça paraît un peu
dérisoire néanmoins à l'époque pour en
fait essayer de pallier à tout ça on
s'est beaucoup aidé des médias pour
lancer des enquêtes et depuis 2015 on a
une dizaine d'enquêtes pour montrer et
structurer en fait toutes les missions
de l'association
pour pouvoir comment accompagner en fait
les professionnels de la santé qui
étaient en souffrance
donc ces enquêtes elles nous ont permis
de structurer l'association en deux
grandes parties l'accompagnement
psychologique de tous les professionnels
de la santé en France et des actions de
préhension pour leur mieux-être parce
que effectivement je pense que l'enjeu
essentiel c'est pas de d'agir en curatif
mais vraiment d'être en prévention alors
je commencerai peut-être mes propos par
le suivant finalement qui sont-ils qui
sont nos professionnels de santé et qui
sont nos professionnels de santé
la définition n'est pas tout à fait
claire d'ailleurs vous voulez appeler
profession du Caire et je trouve que
c'est une très bonne définition parce
que nous je pense on a été les premiers
à recenser l'intégralité ou quasiment de
tous les professionnels que ça soit dans
le secteur public privé hommes femmes de
des professionnels de santé et c'est
plus de 50 métiers on estime qu'une 200
qui sont autour du patient et nous on a
pris en tout cas le parti pris de
s'occuper de tous les professionnels qui
étaient au contact des patients
donc on l'a même recensé sur notre site
ça va évidemment des professions
médicales professions paramédicales mais
aussi toute profession administrative
que ce soit les cadres de santé les DRH
les brancardier les agents techniques
les professions ce qu'on appelait
médico-social et pas celle qui travaille
dans le médico-social mais auxiliaire de
vie assistante
à la mobilité et tout autre profession
de santé y compris vétérinaire parce que
c'est la profession en France alors on
parle du wannels mais en tout cas même
si ils sont pas considérés comme étant
des professionnels de santé ils ont un
très très grand en tout cas une très
grande souffrance puisqu'ils enregistre
le plus gros taux de suicide En France
voilà par rapport à cette profession
donc c'est 3500
000 en tout cas qu'on a répertorié et
ces chiffres sont à votre disposition
puisqu'on a fait un gros travail de en
tout cas de d'épidémiologie sur sur ces
chiffres
pourquoi parce que quand on fait appel à
l'association les gens me disent ah bah
est-ce que je peux vous appeler bah oui
et c'est comme ça qu'on a effectivement
vraiment défini qui était notre cible
pour s'occuper de alors dans l'émission
qu'on a pourquoi je vous parle de ces
missions parce que on a je pense le plus
bel observatoire de la santé des
soignants en France par la plateforme
qu'on a mis à disposition depuis 2016
qui est une plateforme nationale
d'écoute qui permet d'écouter de
réorienter et d'hospitaliser des
professionnels de la santé qui ne vont
pas bien
et c'est là plus de 25000 appels en six
ans qui nous permet de dire comme Robin
disait tout à l'heure que parmi ces
appels il y a aller quasiment 70% de
femmes l'âge moyen c'est 43 ans et en
fait le profil type d'appel sur notre
plateforme c'est une femme de 43 ans qui
a deux enfants
plutôt l'Île-de-France et qui est
évidemment en souffrance en souffrance
plus ou moins importante puisqu'on
gratte nos appels de 1 à 5 et on peut
effectivement avoir un formidable
observatoire les appels effectivement
les plus importants et les grains de 5
et on a eu notamment 40 appels d'urgence
immédiate de personnes en suicidaires
depuis effectivement mars 2020 donc on a
évidemment
parmi tous ces appels 70% de femmes les
métiers les plus représentés ce sont les
infirmières les aides-soignantes et les
médecins mais l'ensemble des métiers
sont concernés y compris l'ensemble des
régions avec effectivement c'est une
sur-représentation au niveau de
l'Île-de-France les motifs des appels et
je dirais après qu'on n'a pas fait
l'analyse comme femme homme même si on
l'a fait en tout cas pour certains
partenaires des profils en fonction de
leur métier et de leur région puisqu'on
analyse on a une analyse également par
région qui assez peu d'une région à
l'autre puisqu'on retrouve quasiment
systématiquement dans chaque région
entre 66 et 80% d'appels féminins les
motifs des appels en tout cas sont
plurifactoriels et évolue dans le temps
nous avions effectivement mars de
Villemin des motifs d'anxiété pour le
covid mais depuis 2021 les motifs
personnels évoluent énormément donc on
parle beaucoup de qualité de vie au
travail et de mauvaise qualité dit au
travail pour un impact sur la santé mais
depuis 2021 on a beaucoup de motifs
personnels et ça emmène classification
de la react
de perte de sens de perte d'envie de
perte d'attractivité et depuis l'année
dernière on a beaucoup de motifs
d'anxiété et d'appel sur notre
plateforme dû à l'environnement
l'environnement global c'est-à-dire
la guerre la crise gilets jaunes
une perte en tout cas la grève et puis
aussi la pénurie d'essence qui augmente
considérablement en fait l'anxiété des
professionnels eux de santé et aussi une
désorientation par rapport au milieu
familial beaucoup plus de divorce
qu'avant donc c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup
de qualité de vie au travail et d'impact
de troubles musculo-squelettiques etc
mais il ne faut pas oublier aussi
l'impact personnel depuis c'est en tout
cas depuis quelques mois et aussi
environnementale donc oui la santé des
soignantes passe par la qualité de vie
au travail parce qu'elle voit mais pas
de souci par leur santé leur santé
personnelle qui peut être l'activité
physique le sommeil l'alimentation mais
aussi par tout l'environnement qui
impacte considérablement leur santé
on savait alors parmi toutes les
enquêtes que 50% des professionnels de
santé qui ont sont en souffrance
à un impact sur un évidemment sur la
qualité de soi au point de mettre en
danger la vie du patient donc oui une
soignant une soignante qui est pas bien
soigné est un patient qui est moins bien
soigné et ça on a estimé à 50% et
c'était chiffre effectivement très
important alors une fois qu'on a dit ça
de dire il y a un dispositif
d'accompagnement psychologique que l'on
nous a mis en place avec un 100% des
crochets et ça c'est très important
d'avoir ce 100% des crochets et une
cellule d'urgence qui permet de rappeler
ou d'hospitaliser d'urgence nous l'enjeu
en tout cas au niveau de la santé des
soignantes qui est une santé un petit
peu plus fragilisée par rapport à la
santé des soignants nous a permis dès
2018 de mettre en place des actions de
prévention
parce que on s'est rendu compte et cela
d'autres chiffres dont également donné
on s'est rendu compte en fait que la
santé des soignants
avaient été très dégradé surtout les
critères
activités physiques activités
alimentation sommeil addiction voire
même vaccination et ça c'est une étude
qu'on avait monté d'ailleurs avec la MNH
en 2018 qui montait que la santé était
de regarder sur tous les critères et
évidemment on peut estimer avec 80% de
soignantes et de professionnels de santé
en France que les femmes sont très
impactées à tous les niveaux je
reviendrai pas sur ce sujet mais
évidemment c'est cancer du sein trop
muscule au squelettique accident de
travail mais il y a les risques
psychosociaux très importants comme le
burn out la violence épuisement
émotionnelle et j'oublierai pas parce
que souvent l'oublie quand même des
tentatives de suicide pour des femmes y
compris des femmes de santé puisque en
souffrance de façon globale il y a 200
000 tentatives de suicide et que les
femmes sont beaucoup plus impactées sur
les tentatives de suicide avec une
prévence de deux fois plus importante
que les hommes alors que le suicide en
eux-mêmes impact plus les hommes que les
femmes donc ça c'est très important et
nous avons estimé par rapport à des
chiffres certes qui sont pas récents
parce qu'ils font pas trop parler du
suicide En France que trois
professionnels de santé se suffisaient
tous les deux jours avec une une
campagne qui a été d'ailleurs pris au
Festival de la communication santé et ça
c'est très important trois
professionnels de santé se suivent tous
les deux jours j'ai pas les chiffres
pour les professionnels le de santé mais
c'est un chiffre en tout cas qui fait
froid dans le dos et donc il faut
évidemment s'occuper donc pour revenir
aux aspects de prévention il est très
important il est capital de s'occuper de
la prévention des professionnels E2
santé en France
on s'occupe beaucoup effectivement de
tout ce qui est trop muscu
l'osquelettiques maladies infectieux
accident de travail etc mais
qu'en est-il de la prévention et bien il
y en a quasiment pas quand on regarde un
petit peu tout ce qui se passe dans les
dans les hôpitaux et même au niveau des
libéraux et j'oublierai pas les libéraux
puisque nous on a aussi bien des appels
d'hospitaliers mais aussi de
professionnels de santé libérale homme
femme public privé il y en a quasiment
pas et
les les études qu'on avait fait en 2020
ont montré en fait que leur principale
ressources des professionnels de santé
n'étaient pas dans l'approche
thérapeutique n'était pas dans
l'approche psy mais à plus de 70% il y a
trois études qui nous montrent ça à la
fin du covid que ça soit au niveau
libéral ou salle ou même ou même
hospitalière au niveau des inf des
préparatrices en officine et des
Hospitalières ont montré que leurs
ressources c'était dans tout ce qui
était approche non médicamenteuse qui
maintenant sont des en tout cas une
société savante qui s'appelle line peace
qui ont prouvé scientifiquement qu'un
certain nombre d'approchement
médicamenteux intervention dans
médicamentseuses et je parle pas la
médecine complémentaire avait un fort
impact sur les ressources des soignants
c'est pourquoi et ça c'est des
initiatives et je l'ai vu dans le
questionnaire qu'est-ce qui existe en
France en termes d'initiatives de
prévention en tout cas au niveau de
l'association on en a donné beaucoup
puisqu'on a organisé dès 2019 des
journées de préhension déclinés dans les
hôpitaux et les structures de santé
autour de quatre thématiques la gestion
du stress le management et la
communication tout ce qui était mode de
vie alimentation et prévoyant ses droits
ces quatre thématiques sont issues
d'enquêtes pour permettre pour répondre
à des besoins d'amélioration de la santé
des soignants de la la dimension de leur
santé et c'est plus de 50 ateliers qui
ont été mises en oeuvre effectivement
par l'association pour répondre à son
besoin avec plus de 90% de toute
satisfaction donc je pense que l'enjeu
il est vraiment là comment ressourcer
les professionnels de santé comment
prévenir en fait leur santé c'est un
vrai débat qui est des actions qui sont
qui sont mises en place en tout cas au
niveau de l'association SPS avec des
lieux physiques aussi on a créé la
première maison des soignants on devrait
l'appeler maison des soignantes alors
peut-être je finirai mes propos sur ce
sujet plus que on a quasiment que des
femmes qui viennent à la maison des
soignantes à Paris qui est un lieu où on
fait des entretiens de psychologue on se
forme on s'informe et on a des ateliers
de ressources on a des groupes de
reconversion et des groupes de parole
qui permettent à ces femmes quand je dis
il y en a un de temps en temps c'est
bien le maximum on a eu plus de 1000
visites depuis 18 mois et c'est
quasiment que des femmes qui à cette
maison des soignants pour essayer de
trouver un échange de ressources et je
finirai par de dire cercle la bonne
santé des femmes c'est physique
psychique et social et je pense aussi
qu'il faut redonner du sens à leur
métier aussi par l'attractivité sociale
l'écoute avec leur passion l'écoute avec
leur patientes on parle beaucoup de
cancers on parle beaucoup de troubles
musculo-squelettiques on parle beaucoup
de de mise en place dans ce cadre-là
revenons à des choses fondamentales dont
elles ont besoin quand on les interroge
elles ont besoin certes être en bonne
santé mais ils ont aussi besoin d'avoir
une reconnaissance et d'être écoutée
d'avoir un échange avec leur passion
pour continuer à exercer leur métier
je vous remercie en tout cas pour
m'avoir écouté au-delà de tous ces
propos on a fait un formidable travail
alors nous on n'est pas là MNH on a une
toute petite association on est trois
salariés mais on a j'ai fait appel à mes
bénévoles sur la région pour vous donner
par rapport à votre questionnaire une
très bonne revue bibliographique puisque
on a il y a beaucoup d'études il y a
beaucoup d'enquêtes qui ont été faites
qui sont pas forcément publiées donc
elles sont un peu cachées nous-mêmes on
en a fait une dizaine alors évidemment
elles sont un peu générales et pas
forcément adaptées aux femmes néanmoins
il y a quand même pas mal d'informations
qui pourront en tout cas vous aider à
faire votre magnifique travail qui va
être utile pour l'ensemble des
soignantes en France et leur donner et
leur donner en tout cas beaucoup
beaucoup d'espoir et enfin de s'occuper
d'elle voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention et à votre disposition pour
les échanges pour tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup madame c'est vrai que
cette cela vient compléter
utilement le propos de Monsieur more et
je pense que votre intervention fera
forcément réagir les rapporteurs qui
sont avec nous ce matin Laurence
Rossignol Marie-Pierre Richer et Annick
je vais tout de suite passer la parole à
Béatrice Bart qui est maître de
conférence en ergonomie et experte pour
lances à vous madame
merci madame la présidente madame
mesdames les rapporteurs mesdames
messieurs je vous remercie de votre
invitation alors la demande qui n'est
faite aujourd'hui et de présenter des
recherches sur les temps de travail
atypiques notamment sur le travail de
nuit pourquoi mais parce que c'est tant
de travail atypique ne sont pas anodin
ne sont pas en risque sur la santé parce
qu'ils sont fréquents voire habituelles
dans les métiers du Caire notamment du
soin et parce que ce secteur est
fortement féminisé donc c'est donc par
cette porte d'entrée celle des horaires
que je vais aborder la santé des femmes
dans les métiers féminisés lors de cette
table ronde la santé mais également le
travail qu'elles font dans les services
et qui leur permet de préserver leur
santé
je précise que le point de vue adopté
dans mon propos liminaire se place d'une
part dans le cadre d'une expertise
collective menée à l'enses l'Agence
nationale de sécurité sanitaire entre
2012 et 2016 avec 17 autres experts dont
Florence chaper que vous avez
accueillies il y a quelques semaines je
crois ici au sujet des risques
sanitaires et dit au travail de nuit
d'autre part le point de vue adopté dans
ce propos liminaire se place également
dans le cadre de mes activités de
chercheuse en ergonomie c'est-à-dire en
fait dans le cadre de recherche action
que je mène dans les situations de
travail en contexte avec des analyses
ciblées qualitatives qui vise à repérer
à comprendre les réalités du travail et
ses exigences et ce dont dans le secteur
du Caire depuis début de ma carrière
notamment dans le secteur hospitalier
alors tout d'abord le travail du MI des
femmes le poids des horaires sur la
santé peut-être quelques définitions
définir d'abord ce que sont les horaires
atypiques donc ce sont des horaires en
fait qui renvoient à une multitude de
réalité qui passe par le travail tôt le
matin tard le soir la nuit mais
également par le travail du samedi du
dimanche par le travail les longues
journées de travail plus de plus de 11
heures plus de 12 heures ce qui arrive
souvent les de 127 hospitalier sont
assez ont beaucoup de succès mais
également il doit imprévisible donc une
un ensemble de réalité en fait autour de
son englobées par ce terme très général
autre définition c'est le travail de
nuit qui est donc une des formes de
temps de travail atypique il est défini
donc dans le code du travail comme tout
travail accompli entre 21h et 6h du
matin cette période de dégâts du travail
peut-être remplacée par une autre
période négociée et définie par rapport
collectif de branches étendues ou par
corps d'entreprise ce qui est souvent le
cas incluant obligatoirement la plage
compris entre minuit et 5 heures du
matin
alors les données donc les données à
disposition concernant le travail de
ratypique alors j'ai cherché les études
en fait qui alliés horaires atypique
femmes et secteur du soin juste rappeler
peut-être une étude que vous devez
connaître d'être de la DARES sur le
uniquement sur le travail de nuit qui a
été publié à quelques temps mais qui me
semble intéressantes en 2014 qui montre
en fait sur des données de 2012 que 15%
des salariés travaillent travailler la
nuit en 2012 donc c'est à peu près 3,5
millions pardon de personnes
cette étude de la DS montre que le
travail de nuit se cumule avec d'autres
formes de ratypiques des horaires
alternants des horaires variables d'une
semaine sur l'autre du travail du soir
du travail de fin de semaine
et cette étude montre également que les
métiers du Caire du soin font partie des
cinq familles professionnelles comptant
le plus de travailleurs de nuit ils
identifient en fait les conducteurs de
véhicules en premier les policiers les
militaires puis viennent ensuite les
infirmières les aides-soignantes
voilà au niveau des personnes les plus
concernées par ces horaires particuliers
plus récemment une autre étude de la
déesse qui était publiée donc en 2022
sur des données 2017-2019 analyse et le
temps de travail par métier et elle nous
apprend donc parmi les infirmières et
les sages-femmes 22% d'entre elles
travaillent à nuit elle travaille
également le samedi le dimanche je
présente pas les chiffres peut-être dans
le détail et parmi les aides de
soignantes 15% également travaillent la
nuit sachant que bien sûr vous l'avez
dit la large la majorité 91% d'entre
elles sont des femmes
alors la question du travail de nuit et
des liens avaient la santé
a été abordé dans les littérature
scientifiques depuis assez longtemps on
a des travaux depuis un certain temps
qui nous montrent qu'on est fait le
travail de nuit à des effets sur la
santé pourquoi parce que travailler la
nuit perturbe l'alternance veille
sommeil et des synchronise nos rythmes
biologiques notamment ce qu'on appelle
les rythmes circadiens c'est-à-dire les
rythmes qui ont une période sur une
journée de 24 heures ces rythmes là ils
sont contrôlés par une horloge interne
au corps au coeur pardon de notre
cerveau qui règle toutes les grandes
fonctions de notre organisme et qui
chaque jour en fait est remise à l'heure
elle est remise à l'heure à cette
horloge d'une part par l'alternance de
la lumière et de l'obscurité du jour et
de la nuit et elle est remise à l'heure
également par des repères temporels de
la vie sociale les heures d'ouverture
des crèches des écoles des commerces les
heures du repex etc or la situation de
travail de nuit
provoque un conflit en fait entre ces
différentes temporalités puisqu'elle
oblige les travailleurs les
travailleuses en l'occurrence de nuit à
dormir pendant leur journée biologique
et inversement être actif pendant leur
nuit biologique et c'est cette
désynchronisation biologique des rythmes
associés à une dette chronique de
sommeil due au travail de nuit qui
provoque des effets sur la santé
alors les conclusions de l'expertise
collective de l'inceste dont je vous
parlais mais en évidence des effets avec
différents niveaux de preuves je vais
passer assez vite un niveau de preuve
avéré qui est le plus haut niveau en
fait qui montre que le travail de nuit a
des effets sur la somnolence sur les
troubles du sommeil et sur le syndrome
métabolique des effets probables sur la
santé psychique ou par l'identité de
dépression de Burnout sur les
performances cognitives sur l'obésité la
prise de poids le diabète et les
maladies coronariennes et des effets
possibles sur l'augmentation des lipides
dans le sang l'hypertension artérielle
et les accidents vasculaires cérébraux
ça fait pas rêver
alors considérant le cancer puisque
c'était un peu la demande l'expertise
conclut à un effet probable du travail
de nuit sur le risque de cancer et plus
particulièrement du coup je voulais vous
présenter une étude qui a eu lieu suite
enfin qui est plus récente que le
rapport en 16 qui a été publié en 2018
qui a été mené par Pascal guenel
spécialiste ces questions là qui
d'ailleurs faisait partie du groupe de
lances et qui apporte cette étude de
nouvelles informations sur l'association
entre travail de nuit risque de cancer
du sein donc cette étude en fait
réanalyse 5 études qui ont été menées en
Australie au Canada en Allemagne en
Espagne et en France
qui permettent de retracer l'exposition
au travail de nuit de 13000 femmes la
moitié d'entre elles ayant eu un cancer
du sein l'autre moitié étant saine en
bonne santé les analyses qui ont été
menées à partir de cette grande base de
données montre
premièrement que le travail de nuit
augmente de 26% le risque d'avoir un
cancer du sein
second élément important cette étude
montre que le risque croit augmente chez
les femmes qui ont travaillé plus de
deux nuits par semaine pendant plus de
10 ans
précisons que le cirque Centre
International de la recherche contre le
cancer qui est une agence de l'OMS qui
avait déjà classé en 2007 que le travail
de posté avec lui comme agent
probablement cancérogène a conclu en
2019 sur la base d'indications limitée
que le travail de nuit posté non
seulement était un facteur de risque du
cancer du sein mais également de celui
du cancer de la prostate et du cancer
colorectal
alors concernant le cancer du sein et la
question de la reconnaissance vous vous
en parliez en effet vous l'avez rappelé
début février 2023 une infirmière
habitant en Moselle qui a travaillé à
l'hôpital durant 28 ans a obtenu la
reconnaissance en cancer du sein comme
maladie professionnelle c'est une
décision inédite
jusqu'à cette décision en fait février
2023 et malgré les pathologies associées
à ce type d'horaire il n'y avait pas en
France de il n'y avait jamais eu en
France maladie professionnelle reconnue
comme étant liée au travail de nuit le
seul exemple d'une indemnisation obtenue
par des salariés liés à cette à cette
contrainte du travail nous nous venait
d'une Danemark qui a accordé en 2008
indemnités à 37 femmes atteinte d'un
cancer du sein pouvant être lié au
travail de nuit des infirmières
également
ainsi le cas de cette infirmière
française pourrait faire jurisprudence
et permettre à d'autres atteintes de
cette maladie d'être indemnisée les
enjeux sont colossaux pour les victimes
et pour les employeurs
alors maintenant je vais faire un zoom
beaucoup plus près du réel des réalités
des services hospitaliers des métiers du
Caire parce que au-delà donc au-delà des
déterminants physiologiques du temps de
travail de leurs effets sur la santé que
j'ai essayé présenté dans ma première
partie de cette présentation d'iminaire
il est important quand même de souligner
que travailler la nuit à l'hôpital dans
un EHPAD ou c'est pas seulement être
bousculé de façon passive par ces
rythmes biologiques c'est aussi pour
certaines un choix extrêmement
satisfaisant un sentiment de gagner du
temps sur sa vie un gain financier une
opportunité pour s'occuper de ses
enfants aller les chercher à l'école les
ramener à l'école les couchers avant de
partir travailler et aussi c'est
l'opportunité de travailler dans un
environnement qui est plus calme
d'apprendre et de toute façon dans les
métiers dans ces métiers là duquel la
question des horaires est une contrainte
connue et acceptée dès la formation
pour d'autres ou les mêmes personnes
mais à d'autres moments de leur vie
travailler de nuit va être plus
difficile parce que les problèmes de
santé vont commencer à apparaître parce
que les enfants vont arriver et que du
coup la conciliation la vie personnelle
va être plus compliquée
dans tous les cas pour tenir l'équilibre
entre ces différentes dimensions les
salariés les personnels soignants vont
mettre activement en place dans le réel
du travail et dans le réel du hors
travail ce qu'on appelle des processus
de régulation qui vise à minimiser les
impacts des horaires sur la santé et
donc c'est ce que je vais un petit peu
illustrer s'il me reste un petit peu de
temps
voilà avec mon regard d'ergonome et les
analyses de terrain que je mène dans les
services
hospitaliers voilà je vais vous
présenter quelques résultats qui
montrent que le travail qui est mis en
oeuvre dans le réel peut être bien
différent du prescrit parce que adapter
à la fois à l'état fonctionnel à l'état
dans lequel sont les personnes
lorsqu'elles travaillent et la nuit et
le matin tôt le matin ou tard le soir et
adap TER bien sûr aux exigences de leur
travail et donc à la à la préservation
de la santé du soigner
alors premier type de stratégie
identifié dans l'activité de travail
c'est une stratégie qui vise à anticiper
et à se réserver des marges de manœuvre
pour faire face aux mieux aux aléas ça
c'est un exemple qui a été
étudiants qui ont montré cette stratégie
là mais un exemple que je vous donne a
été mené dans une service de pneumologie
pardon où les infirmières vont s'assurer
dès le début de poste que les
prescriptions médicales permettent de
prendre en charge l'éventuelle anxiété
nocturne des patients un service de
pneumologie il y a beaucoup de patients
sont extrêmement des pathologies très
lourdes ils sont extrêmement anxieux la
nuit
elles vont également s'arranger pour
faire la tournée des chambres plutôt
possible afin de rencontrer un maximum
de patients éveillés et elles vont ainsi
se construire une représentation précise
de leur état de santé afin d'être en
mesure d'anticiper au mieux le
déroulement de la nuit en suivant
un autre résultat si on Réal du travail
de nuit concerne le fait de pouvoir
transférer certains tâches les avancées
les cumuler au cours du poste même si ça
va l'encontre des prescriptions dans un
service de réanimation par exemple nous
avons montré que les soignants avancent
un maximum de tâches en début de poste
comme l'étiquetage des bidons sanguins
la préparation d'israingue ou le relevé
des constantes parce que prendre de
l'avance leur permet d'avoir une vision
précise de la charge de travail à venir
et de se rendre disponible pour gérer
les urgences potentielles et
l'augmentation de leur somnolence
je reviens sur l'idée que c'est
stratégie fines que l'on met en
visibilité ce sont des façons de
travailler qui leur permettent de
préserver leur santé de mieux soigner
les patients et donc de préserver leur
santé c'est le lien que vous avez fait
également dans votre dans votre
intervention autre stratégie identifiée
au niveau du collectif au niveau du
collectif de soignants le collectif
constitue une ressource capitale pour
pour maîtriser les risques notamment en
situation de travail de nuit au moment
du pic de fatigue et là par exemple dans
un service de néonatologie nous avons
montré que lorsque des actes infirmiers
nécessitent une concentration maximale à
3 ou 4 heures du matin systématiquement
ces actes sont faits à trois à deux
personnes ou trois personnes pour plus
de sécurité auprès du patient et pour
voilà pour être pour plus de fiabilité
collective également et enfin autre
autre exemple lorsque le travail le
permet on observe également bien souvent
des stratégies de repos voire de prise
de sieste pour essayer de gérer la
fatigue et la qualité des soins c'est ce
que nous avons montré dans un service de
soins intensif dans lequel les
personnels soignants avaient la
possibilité de prendre du repos ou même
de faire une sieste parce que il y avait
une tolérance voir des encouragements de
la cadre c'est qu'un ce qui est très
rare et dans cette étude on montre que
si dans 25% des cas les personnes
soignants ne peuvent pas prendre ni
repos ni sieste parce que de toute façon
la nuit est trop chargée lorsque ils
peuvent leur se prendre une sieste ou
une période de repos est possible dans
16% des cas alors le niveau de
somnolence remonte significativement en
fin de poste lorsque le poste de nid
dure 12 heures c'est important ce qui
engage de fiabilité pour notamment pour
la relève sans parler du gage de
fidélité pour le retour en voiture au
domicile
enfin les horaires de travail
définissent de fait aussi les horaires
du hors travail de la vie personnelle de
la vie familiale et les études montrent
que les activités de ces activités de
conciliation mise en place pour pour
gérer le travail et le leur travail sont
différentes selon le genre avec des
difficultés majeures pour les femmes
alors il existe des travaux dans la
littérature depuis longtemps sur le
sujet ils ont identifié des stratégies
particulières notamment auprès de
personnes qui travaillent en 3-8 et
ennui c'est une stratégie se manifeste
d'une part par à la maison vous parliez
de la vie personnelle de la vie
familiale et de ce qui se passe à la
maison je pense que en effet c'est très
important des stratégies qui se
manifestent par une organisation
individuelle très rigide autour de la
prise de repas et de la prise de sieste
et d'autre part par des accords qui sont
trouvés au sein de la famille avec la
conjointe des enfants qui vivent au
rythme au plus près du rythme du
travailleur posté ou de nuit du père
alors je parle de père parce que ces
travaux portent
majoritairement dans auprès de personnes
auprès d'hommes pardon une population
masculine dans l'industrie lorsque
l'individu qui travaille en aurait
atypique ou de nuit est une femme alors
on n'a pas du tout on observe pas du
tout les mêmes stratégies de
conciliation
pour les raisons qui sont liées au
stéréotypes au rôle sociaux induits par
le genre on observe des titres de
stratégies des stratégies de choix
d'horaires particuliers pour être en
mesure de s'occuper des enfants en
journée ou en semaine c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est de
soignantes des infirmières qui vont
choisir de travailler la nuit pour
s'occuper des enfants en journée bon
comment dans ces conditions de trouver
du temps pour récupérer
autre type de stratégie on observe dans
pendant le temps de travail lorsque il y
a assez de souplesse dans la situation
une gestion des responsabilités
familiales du pendant le temps de
travail c'est-à-dire des personnes voilà
qui vont appeler à 23h pour vérifier que
les enfants sont bien couchés que le
dîner a bien été il y a pas le feu à la
maison parce que voilà c'est le grand
qui a fait des pâtes donc voilà c'est il
y a un auteur espagnol qui parle du
double présence dans la sphère
personnelle
du travail et qui amène souvent les
femmes à une sensation de double absence
avec un sentiment d'impuissance dans les
deux sphères donc on voit aussi en quoi
ça peut être source d'épuisement alors
pour pour conclure
au niveau des recommandations là par
rapport aux recommandations que qui ont
été évoquées avant donc vous l'aurez
compris par rapport aux travaux que je
mène l'idée plus amener des choses au
niveau de la prévention primaire et au
niveau d'analyse plus contextualisé pour
identifier dans le réel les déterminants
de la santé au travail parce qu'on se
rend compte en fait que
par exemple même avec des mêmes horaires
de travail même avec dans les mêmes
services hospitaliers dans les réalités
on n'a pas la même chose qui se joue
donc l'idée en fait pour conclure c'est
de mettre de faire des études de
poursuivre les études et c'est ce qu'on
a aussi poussé au niveau de la au niveau
de la ne cesse pour rendre visible ces
analyses et ces stratégies que les
soignants et les soignantes surtout
mettent en place pour maintenir cet
équilibre et à partir de là moi je
propose en tout cas je vous présenterai
je vous présente de différents niveaux
d'action qui peuvent être investigués
conjointement me semble-t-il le premier
c'est le travail sur la modification du
système horaire alors bien sûr dans le
secteur du Caire supprimer le travail de
nuit ça c'est pas
ceci étant on a quand même il y a
beaucoup de on peut mener des réflexions
sur trouver un système horaire qui
minimise la désynchronisation
circadienne qui favorise la récupération
la dette de sommeil et qui permettent de
concilier au mieux la vie perso et la
vie professionnelle le succès de 12 ans
hospitalier permet
vient de là en fait second type de
d'action des actions au niveau du
travail des conditions de travail du
contenu de travail parce que voilà par
rapport à l'ergonomie nous ce qu'on dit
souvent est-ce qu'on se connaissait
faire dans nos interventions c'est de
soigner l'organisation du travail à
l'idée c'est de soigner l'organisation
du travail pour soigner les personnes
qui travaillent ici les soignants
donc dans ce dans ces actions sur les
conditions de travail du contenu de
travail il y a beaucoup de choses je
vais peut-être pas tout développé mais
c'est en lien les recherches que j'ai
présenté juste avant les choses autour
de l'anticipation de l'augmentation des
marges de manoeuvre la question de
pouvoir anticiper des périodes de repos
l'importance de soutenir le travail
collectif quand on voit qu'on a les
équipes de nuit
on vide les équipes de nuit dans le
secteur hospitalier c'est quand même la
catastrophe avec des des dans les EHPAD
nous n'en parlons pas et qu'on voit
l'importance de la dimension collective
la nuit donc des actions autour de des
activités de l'activité collective
ensuite une série d'actions autour de
l'activité de conciliation entre la vie
de travail la vie au travail et enfin
juste bien se développer un petit peu
plus une action mais je n'ai pas trop
parler une action au niveau des parcours
professionnels il me semble essentiel
travailler sur les parcours
professionnels et sur la gestion des
ressources humaines parce que maîtriser
le risque lié aux horaires atypiques et
c'est aussi l'envisagé sur l'ensemble de
la carrière professionnelle afin
d'éviter de maintenir les salariés dans
ce type d'horaire de trop longues années
dans un contexte d'allongement des
carrières dans le cadre de la réforme
des retraites ce dernier levier me
semble essentiel voilà je vous remercie
de votre attention
et bien merci beaucoup à tous les trois
pour cette ces interventions qui nous
éclairent déjà un peu plus sur le
déficit de prévention sur
ce qui a été mis en place au niveau de
la maison des soignants qui nous paraît
très intéressant forcément on aura
peut-être besoin peut-être d'avoir des
informations un peu plus précises sur
sur cette maison des soignants et sur
finalement son organisation son
articulation
au sein de ces de la structure globale
et puis peut-être une précision avant de
laisser la parole à mesdames les
rapporteurs une précision sur la
statistique que vous avez donné tout à
l'heure sur trois professionnels de
santé qui se suicident tous les deux
jours est-ce que cette statistique
inclut les suicides des vétérinaires
parce qu'on sait que la proportion de
vétérinaires est très élevée donc est-ce
qu'on pourrait avoir les chiffres
éventuellement or statistiques
vétérinaire ce qui permettrait quand
même d'avoir un chiffre un peu plus
affiné
c'était une première question mais je
vais laisser très rapidement je vous
laisse madame si vous le souhaitez
répondre je vais laisser ensuite la
parole aux trois rapports qui sont avec
nous ce matin
oui merci pour les questions peut-être
juste un mot sur la maison des soignants
qui initiative l'association
SPS qui a été créé en tout cas en 2000
et ouvert en 2021
c'est une initiative association on est
hébergé à Paris pour l'instant par l'uf
chirurgien-dentiste de France où on
rouleaux et on a à ce jour en fait à la
fois des entretiens avec des
psychologues qui sont gratuits pour des
personnes en tout cas les soignants qui
viennent à cette maison des soignante on
fait nos formations et toutes les
informations en présentiel à cette
maison des soignants on fait également
c'est vrai des groupes de reconversion
groupe de parole bilances pour santé sur
rendez-vous puisqu'on incite qui
s'appelle maison des soignants.fr
et on fait également des journées
thématiques on a fait une journée
thématique il y a pas longtemps avec un
groupe d'infirmières qui étaient en
reconversion pour leur donner en tout
cas des ressources et des informations
pour pouvoir se reconvertir on fait une
d'autres journées thématique notamment
on a fait le suicide on a fait des
aidants on en fait une bientôt sur les
droits et les démarches des soignants
notamment en libéral donc c'est une
structure effective
qui est à ce jour et je tiens le
préciser très peu financé pourquoi parce
qu'on a perdu nos contacts à une
dernière au niveau de la région de
France et la RSI de France donc on a eu
des financements très tard donc à notre
avis on le déploie pas comme il pourrait
développer en tout cas et le besoin qui
pourrait être très important au niveau
de Paris et on pourrait largement ouvrir
d'autres maisons des soignants et c'est
un peu le projet à Paris mais aussi dans
d'autres dans d'autres villes notamment
il y a messe et Montpellier qui sont en
je veux dire en négociation mais
l'objectif c'est d'ouvrir au moins une
maison des soignants en physiquement
dans chaque région et des travailler
également sur la mobilité pour avoir des
antennes pour être au plus proche des
professionnels de la santé pour pouvoir
vraiment les accompagner donc ça c'est
la première question pour la deuxième la
deuxième question concernant le suicide
de professionnels de santé c'est un
chiffre qui est assez cartésien pourquoi
parce qu'on a énormément de chiffres du
mal d'avoir déjà des chiffres sur
suicide en France les derniers chiffres
officiels de 2017 et effectivement le
ministère de la Santé travaille sur une
grosse campagne de prévention de suicide
il est temps puisque nos autres pays
européens ont des déchets beaucoup plus
récents qui donnent de 2021 et avec ça
on est trois points au dessus de la
moyenne européenne dans la dans la
prévention de suicide puisqu'on a un
taux de prévalence à 14%.000 habitants
alors que dans les autres pays européens
c'est plutôt 11%.000 habitants ce qui
est énorme et effectivement il faut
vraiment s'en occuper alors vous avez
effectivement parler des vétérinaires ou
le taux de suicide et entre deux à
quatre fois plus important que la
population générale c'est une étude de
l'ordre des vétérinaires qui a eu lieu
en un dernier j'ai pas le chiffre
hors vétérinaire vous comprendrez
pourquoi parce qu'en fait nous on a fait
une règle assez simple on a pris 3,5
millions
professionnels de santé en France et on
a fait une règle de trois par rapport à
la population française au dessus de 15
ans donc c'est un minimum parce que dans
ce chiffre là on tient pas compte de la
prévalence effectivement qui est
supérieure mais assez hétérogène entre
les différents professions de santé on
sait par exemple que les médecins il y a
plusieurs enquêtes qui nous montrent que
ces deux fois plus que la population
générale mais les autres on sait pas on
sait pas autant c'est bien spécifié sur
les policiers et d'ailleurs notre
plateforme est également celle de des
policiers c'est la petite parenthèse
mais au niveau des professionnels de
santé or vétérinaire j'aurais beaucoup
de mal à vous dire mais en tout cas les
trois professionnels de la santé qui
suscitent tous les deux jours et un
chiffre sous-estimé effectivement ça
fait froid dans le dos et évidemment
dans ce chiffre on parle pas que des
médecins ou des soignants ou des
paramédicaux on prend l'ensemble des
patients du Caire et c'est vrai que
c'est un chiffre qui est rapporté à 3,5
millions en France voilà ça je vous
donnerai également le calcul qu'on a
qu'on a fait pour pour vous montrer
effectivement plus ce chiffre est aussi
également sous-estimé merci beaucoup
madame je vais désormais passer pour un
échange avec vous la parole laissez la
parole aux rapporteur avec tout d'abord
notre collègue Marie Pierre Richer
merci Présidente je rebondis madame sur
votre intervention concernant les les
maisons les maisons des soignants pour
vous dire qu'il en existe aussi en
centre dans la région Centre Val de
Loire et notamment dans le département
du Cher ça a été développé c'est
rattaché au centre hospitalier george
sand qui est un centre hospitalier
psychiatrique et ça a été développé
également par par une association et je
tiens à dire que c'est développé avec
avec des fonds privés parce que moi je
regrette que qu'au niveau du
au niveau du ministère on s'empare pas
plus de ces maisons de ces maisons des
soignants et que ce sont des initiatives
associatives avec avec des fondations
d'entreprises qui s'y intéressent et
pour l'avoir visité et avoir et avoir vu
ça de près je sais que les soignants te
ont eu du mal à y aller parce que ça
c'était considéré et je mets plein de
guillemets comme comme une faiblesse
mais ensuite elles se sont emparée de de
cette maison et c'est aussi un moment
d'échange qu'elle ne trouve plus au
quotidien tellement les rythmes sont
intenses donc c'est pour ça je voulais
rebondir sur les maisons les maisons des
soignants monsieur tout à l'heure vous
avez fait une petite parenthèse par
rapport à la maison
dans quelque chose qui est un peu
anonyme et confidentiel et toute le
concept des maisons des soignants ici
par l'association SS c'est en dehors de
structure de santé pour pour vraiment
aussi échanger avec d'autres
professionnels de santé
voilà mais je trouve que c'est très très
complémentaire évidemment oui enfin moi
je trouve que c'est une bonne initiative
qu'elle soit accolée ou ou éloigné parce
que on sent que ça répond à quand même à
un besoin mais si je rebondir j'ai noté
concernant le les campagnes de dépistage
et notamment des cancers tout à l'heure
vous avez parlé que les soignants
mettait plus de temps à aller vers le
dépistage donc ma question elle est
est-ce que c'est le travail de nuit et
je n'en doute pas puisque ça a été
reconnu mais quelle est la proportion du
travail de nuit par exemple dans le
cancer du sein par rapport au dépistage
qui serait tardif donc ça c'était une
première je déroule mes questions
ensuite vous avez évoqué
l'enquête qui a été faite par par votre
organisme je voudrais savoir si vous
avez une analyse plus fine en fonction
de la taille des établissements
parce que je pense que le rythme n'est
pas le même en fonction d'analyse
d'établissements entre établissements
publics et privés rural et urbain et en
fonction des services des services dans
lesquels travail les soignants parce que
peut-être qu'il y a je sais pas que tous
les je pense au cas service n'est facile
mais peut-être qu'il y a aussi des
services qui sont plus en difficulté et
dans ces conditions-là est-ce du au
manque de personnel puisqu'on s'est
quand même que que l'hôpital est en
souffrance est dû au manque de personnel
et dans ces conditions là est-ce que
c'est plus la condition de travail avec
son organisation comme vous en avez
parlé madame tout à l'heure ou le
contenu du travail parce qu'on a évoqué
aussi la perte de sens quand on côtoie
les personnes qui travaillent dans les
métiers de la santé on s'aperçoit que
toutes ces personnes aiment leur métier
ensuite c'est le travail en lui je sais
pas si on peut faire la distinction
philosophique entre le métier et le
travail parce que c'est quand même aussi
ce qui ce qui fait cette nuance vous
avez parlé des infirmiers on voit aussi
beaucoup d'infirmières qui quittent le
milieu hospitalier pour aller vers le
libéral donc ça peut aussi ça peut aussi
interroger je voulais savoir si vous
aviez été contacté par le ministère qui
mène actuellement une mission sur la
santé des soignants
et puis après je vais laisser
je pense que j'ai fait le tour si
j'avais quand même une question est-ce
que vous avez aussi
fait une une enquête sur le taux
d'encadrement parce que effectivement
moi il y a de personnel plus la charge
de travail est reportée sur les autres
donc voilà après je laisse mes collègues
poursuivre merci merci beaucoup madame
la rapporteur donc je vous laisse
répondre monsieur more
pour ces questions alors sur le
dépistage tardif c'est une étude
internationale donc ça représente débit
parce que les campagnes de dépistage
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes à
l'international que que qu'en France
mais globalement ça fait la
démonstration que une femme médecin à
2,64 fois plus de risques d'être
diagnostiqué d'un cancer de stade 4 au
moment de son diagnostic que la
population générale parce qu'il y a une
participation moindre en tout cas dans
cette étude on vous la transmettra si si
nécessaire il y a une participation
moindre campagne de dépistage et donc on
se fait dépister à partir du moment où
on commence à avoir
des problématiques de santé qui
s'expriment et donc mécaniquement on se
surexpose à un risque de cancer avancé
comparativement à la population générale
est-ce que c'est la question
du travail de nuit de l'équipe vie
Provis perso est-ce que c'est sur
d'autres problématiques ça les études ne
le disent pas et c'est bien toute la
problématique que j'exposais au départ
de mon propos qui on manque de données
un peu plus exploratoire sur les
déterminants qu'est-ce qui fait
aujourd'hui qu'un soignant se soigne moi
ou partie moins en campagne des
dépistage que la population générale
aujourd'hui de la littérature est un peu
on va dire muette sur le sujet et ça
mérite d'avoir des études
complémentaires qui soient quantitatives
et qualitative madame parler des études
qualitatives tout à l'heure sur
l'ergonomie au travail et la réalité
plus concrète sur le terrain ben
effectivement on va avoir un double
regard à mener c'est un peu l'objet des
travaux que que va mener notre fondation
avec avec l'adresse pour avoir des
études quantitatives sur le taux de
recours effectif à ses campagnes ensuite
on aura des études plus qualitatives à
mener sur pourquoi vous y allez pas si
jamais on
vous avez une réalité
un peu plus malheureuse anti tenir
compte c'est que globalement les
inégalités socio-démographiques ou
socioprofessionnelles qui s'appliquent à
la population générale s'applique aussi
à la population
hospitalière et que certaines catégories
professionnelles qui sont plus exposées
des problématiques d'inégalités sociales
ou de rémunération ont des
préoccupations qui ne sont pas en
priorité sur leur état de santé et qui
sont sur d'autres problématiques et donc
on retrouve des billets en population
générale qu'on va retrouver dans la
population hospitalière une
aide-soignante la salle principale
préoccupation du quotidien c'est pas son
diagnostic du concert malheureusement
c'est possiblement
[Musique]
sa qualité de vie en général son
logement son transport et son pouvoir
d'achat c'est des vrais sujets sociétaux
sociaux à tenir compte dans le sujet
après sur l'analyse en fonction de la
taille des établissements la typologie
non les échantillonnages qu'on a ne nous
le permettent pas en tout cas c'est pas
des questions discriminantes qu'on pose
on pose la question sur la profession
pas sur la nature de service et
effectivement les les réalités sont
différentes on parlait de la prise en
charge psychologique
on a enfin on suit avec beaucoup
d'attention ce qui peut être fait sur la
maison des soins sur ce soutien
aux professionnels la réalité du soutien
psychologique qui apportait aux
professionnels c'est pas la même en
psychiatrie vous avez une culture de la
prévention psychologique des
professionnels qui est beaucoup plus
importante que dans d'autres services de
pardon
voilà exactement il y a une culture de
la supervision collective ou
individuelle qui est beaucoup plus
prégnante parce qu'on sait que
l'activité a un impact très fort sur la
psychologie et donc il y a une diversité
une pluralité de notre il faut tenir
compte mais nos études nous permettent
pas aujourd'hui
sur la question du manque de personnel
mais c'est un peu le serpent qui se mord
la queue en réalité enfin aujourd'hui
cette question elle est centrale
c'est à dire que moi vous avez de
personnel plus vous faites peser de la
charge sur ce qui reste plus vous créez
de l'impact du coup mécaniquement sur
l'état de santé plus vous rendez les
carrières une attractive et donc moins
vous attirez le monde et on est un peu
dans le cercle infernal qui fait que
aujourd'hui qu'il le fout de la poule à
générer le problème ça on saura pas mais
en tout cas il y a un vrai sujet
aujourd'hui démographique et c'est pas
que sur la population médicale c'est sur
toutes les professions avec un vrai
sujet de revendre je sais plus qui en
parlait tout à l'heure la question du
sens mais remettre aussi un peu de
positif dans la façon dont on traite la
question hospitalière et la question des
métiers du soin parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que parler à un jeune du soin
quand dans tous les reportages à la
télévision dans les médias qui peut
consulter sur Internet on ne parle que
du marasme à l'hôpital et que de la
situation catastrophique bien qu'il
faille en tenir compte le propos c'est
pas de dire qu'il faut le nier mais on
aura absolument pas ces métiers
attractifs en tout cas on participe à
leur inattractivité donc il y a un vrai
sujet de campagne de promotion de ces
parce qu'on aura pas les carrières
attractives que en ouvrant des places il
faut aussi qu'il y a des jeunes pour
remplir on voit des promotions par
exemple en pharmacie aujourd'hui qui
sont incomplètes des promotions
infirmières vous avez 30% de déperdition
entre le moment où vous rentrez dans
l'école et le moment où vous en sortez
et que ça interroge quand même sur
l'attractivité des métiers enfin sur la
mission santé des soignants
oui on est on est on a été interrogé on
avait en fait partie du tour de table
sur ce sujet comme beaucoup
d'organisations et je pense que c'est
c'était le propos initial que je tenais
c'est on a besoin aujourd'hui que la
pluralité des initiatives qui sont
prises par les acteurs associatifs
privés non lucratifs publics etc soit
coordonnées par une vraie politique
publique qui donne des priorités des
expérotteurs et qui mettent tout le
monde j'ai envie de dire dans une
dynamique de même sens qu'on soit pas
sur des initiatives typiquement
Catherine en parler tout à l'heure sur
le soutien psychologique aujourd'hui il
y a un besoin qui criant est-ce que
c'est le soutien à une initiative
qui est portée par la puissance publique
qui vous êtes opéré par un opérateur
associatif mais qui est généralisé à
l'échelle nationale où est-ce qu'on va
attendre qu'il y ait une
démultiplications d'initiatives locales
qui va faire que bon normalement un
professionnel entre son ordre
l'association SPS la structure enfin ça
complémentaire santé l'assurance maladie
son établissement il va possiblement
avoir la possibilité d'avoir recours à
une structure de soutien psychologique
donc c'est les axes prioritaires qui va
falloir définir pour mettre en oeuvre et
en coordonner tout le monde et sur les
enquêtes sur le taux d'encadrement non
et on est malheureusement pas la fin
malheureusement pour votre question pas
la bonne organisation interrogée sur ce
sujet je pense que c'est plutôt les
fédérations hospitalières interrogé sur
un taux d'encadrement que nous puisque
on ne perd pas nous de soins donc c'est
pas des sujets qu'on est en capacité
d'explorer
merci beaucoup donc je vais passer la
parole à
chaque mère apporteur et peut-être
Laurence Rossignol toutes les deux si
vous pouvez noter les questions puisque
on a une deuxième table ronde après
non alors juste Annick Jacques May et
puis on passe
merci madame la Présidente et bien merci
déjà tous les trois pour pour vos
exposer donc je prendrai mes questions
dans l'ordre des intervenants monsieur
mort vous nous avez parlé qui avait un
nombre conséquent de personnels
hospitaliers qui avait envisagé de
changer de travail et ce que vous avez
le pourcentage de ce qu'ils ont fait et
pourquoi les autres ne vont-ils pas fait
est-ce que finalement c'est parce qu'ils
aiment leur métier c'est un problème de
financement de courage un manque
d'accompagnement voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser ça et vous avez
parlé effectivement des incivilités
auxquelles ils sont confrontés avec un
pourcentage très nettement supérieur aux
autres salariés est-ce que les autres
salariés vous les vous englobez tous les
métiers ou est-ce que vous avez fait la
distinction avec les salariés qui sont
contact du public c'est quand on est
seul dans un bureau on a moins de
risques voilà et ce qu'ils sont intégrés
dans ce
dans ces statistiques et est-ce qu'à
votre connaissance puisqu'on a beaucoup
parlé du dépistage qui est beaucoup
moins bien fait pour les personnels de
santé ce que il y a des propositions de
dépistage qui sont faits en interne
puisque finalement
j'allais dire ça peut être facilité et
c'est d'autant plus surprenant que
finalement ils sont en contact avec les
malades donc ils voient ils voient pour
beaucoup
les conséquences d'un nom dépistage et
d'une prise en charge tardive de ces
maladies
[Musique]
madame cornebêche je vous remercie
d'avoir parlé des vétérinaires parce que
ça a été ma profession
toute ma vie et effectivement je
confirme que dans nos métiers il y a
énormément de suicides mais qui
s'explique aussi parce qu'on a tous les
produits à domicile donc avec
urinaire qui a envie de se suicider
à la facilité technique et matérielle
j'allais dire mais effectivement oui
c'est très connu de notre profession que
c'est une des problématiques alors vous
avez parlé
de la moyenne d'âge dans la plateforme
d'écoute des 43 ans est-ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser est-ce que vous
avez analysé pourquoi c'est autour de
cet âge là où c'est cette moyenne là qui
ressort et
on a parlé monsieur vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure de la poule et de l'oeuf je
poserai la même question entre la vie
personnelle et la vie professionnelle
parce que ce mal-être dont vous avez
parlé en énumérant tout le contexte
l'environnemental aussi bien la guerre
la crise les gilets jaunes l'essence et
puis la perte d'envie l'anxiété du à
l'environnement finalement est-ce que
qui influence ou sur l'autre est-ce que
c'est la vie perso qui influence sur la
vie professionnelle ou est-ce que c'est
la vie professionnelle qui influence sur
la vie perso ou est-ce que c'est un
mixer deux enfin ce qu'on a pu
identifier voilà quelle est l'origine et
puis madame Bart vous avez pas mal parlé
du travail atypique
je vais présenter mes excuses à nos
intervenants d'être arrivé autant en
retard et en franchement la seule bonne
raison que j'ai à donner c'est que
d'habitude c'est 8h30 et j'ai pas
regardé que j'ai pas observé que cette
fois ci était 8h par espèce de
reproduction mécanique de mon emploi du
temps du jeudi matin voilà donc je
risque de faire de remarques d'abord sur
les soignants enfin sur les problèmes de
personnels juste pour vous dire que le
Sénat a voté il y a peu de temps une
proposition de loi sur les ratios
patients soignants votez à l'unanimité
cette proposition de loi et qu'on avait
à ce moment-là dans les travaux
préparatoires à l'adoption
d'approvisionnement même bien identifié
tous les mécanismes d'éviction et de
fuite des hôpitaux qui concernaient
l'ensemble des des personnels soignants
et hospitaliers
et que on déplore que cette proposition
de loi ne soit pas inscrite à l'ordre du
jour de l'Assemblée nationale comme ça
devrait l'être parce que
on peut toujours se poser la question
effectivement sur la poule et l'oeuf
mais on aurait quand même déjà un début
de réponse si on donnait aux soignants
un cadre de travail qui soit dans le
travail sécurisant sur les années à
venir puis après on pourrait se poser la
question de l'oeuf vous pouvez commencer
par quelque chose
commencez commencez par un bon ratio
patience soignante permettrait déjà de
voir beaucoup plus clair
c'était la première remarque que je
voulais faire la deuxième c'est concerne
les suicides mais peut-être comme je
suis arrivé en retard j'ai raté la
réponse à la question et j'en suis
désolé si c'est le cas sur les le taux
de suicide chez les soignants toute
profession confondues est-ce que vous
avez donné la statistique j'en reste à
dire est-ce qu'il y a une prévalence des
suicides chez les femmes par rapport aux
hommes tout en
type de d'activité de profession en
sachant que certaines professions sont
infiniment plus féminisées que les
autres
voilà et par ailleurs merci Madame Bard
d'avoir insisté sur le fait que les
femmes qui travaillent de nuit
concernent totalement la charge mentale
de
la vie domestique et que c'est le
travail de nuit c'est la triple journée
en fait
voilà merci beaucoup donc je vous laisse
vous organiser en sachant qu'on a une
autre audition derrière à 9h30 donc si
vous pouvez être concis mais n'hésitez
pas à répondre aux questions également
du questionnaire que vous aviez reçu si
vous souhaitez nous adresser des mails
complémentaires ils seront les bienvenus
à vous madame Marthe est-ce que je peux
conduire bien sûr merci
par rapport à votre question madame
Jacomet
comment diminuer l'impact des horaires
dans un cadre comme ça où il y a une
continuité 24/24 des soins
justement les actions en fait en tout
cas que que moi que je propose sont des
actions plus contextualisées plus au
niveau au niveau de la de la situation
de travail parce que
on se rend compte que lorsqu'on
accompagne les établissements les
services sur un changement d'horaire et
qu'ensuite
bien sûr le changement d'horaire c'est
une porte d'entrée en fait et qu'ensuite
on travaille la question de la
coordination entre les médecins et les
personnels soignants qu'on travaille la
question des des flux patients qu'on
travaille la question des du temps passé
auprès du patient voilà c'est des choses
qui permettent aussi de de reprendre un
peu le pouvoir sur le travail de et de
préserver sa santé enfin c'est vraiment
des au niveau local je pense en tout cas
qu'ils sont importantes à mettre en
place ensuite sur votre question sur le
chiffre seuil en deçà duquel on n'aurait
pas de cancer du sein
on l'a pas on l'a pas par contre il y a
une voilà il y a pas d'études en effet
qui montre que voilà si on fait que deux
ans si on fait que trois que trois ans
on a alors on a moins de risques en
effet la durée d'exposition augmente le
risque de cancer et des autres
pathologies par contre il y a un
consensus scientifique qui dit qu'en
effet dix ans est un seuil maximal voilà
concernant le travail de nuit
je sais pas si j'ai répondu à votre
question merci est-ce que oui
43 ans c'est un chiffre moyen
effectivement sur notre plateforme
c'est-à-dire qu'on leur demande leur âge
en général quand elle veut bien nous ils
veulent bien nous répondre néanmoins ça
correspond à un âge d'une femme qui a
deux enfants et
souvent qui a plus de difficultés à
s'organiser dans son travail et
monoparentale donc c'est c'est un peu
l'âge moyen d'une femme qui a des qui a
des enfants et qui a leurs enfants en
bas âge mais où il faut vraiment
beaucoup s'occuper des devoirs etc donc
il y a un risque d'anxiété burn out qui
est un peu plus important concernant
votre question sur la vie perso et la
vie professionnelle en fait on sait
qu'un qu'une anxiété clignotise des
appels sur notre plateforme c'est
multifactorielle souvent on nous dit
j'ai mon chef qui m'a pas dit bonjour ce
matin j'ai un plan mais en fait c'est
l'accumulation de plusieurs couches en
tout cas
issus de plusieurs facteurs par contre
ce qu'on sait c'est que depuis deux ans
les motifs personnels sont beaucoup plus
importantes que et ont monté par rapport
au motifs professionnels et ça c'est
aussi par la santé physique psychique et
sociale personnelle et ça va bien
au-delà de la qualité de vie au travail
ça va sur la sur la santé propre la
personne qui à la fois sur personnel
au travail et aussi social je pense
qu'il faut vraiment prendre ces trois
critères en compte moi je suis comme
Robin je suis intégrée dans
l'amélioration de la santé des soignants
en France et dans la feuille de route du
ministère de la Santé je pense qu'il y a
urgence
au-delà de relancer une enquête on a
toutes les enquêtes toutes les études
qui sont à nos disposition il y a
vraiment urgence d'agir parce que quand
on voit qu'il y a deux tiers des
urgentistes qui sont en burn-out et ben
c'est tout le système de soins qui est
branlé et on a parlé de l'encadrement
c'est compliqué donc faut vraiment
vraiment agir vite pour la santé de nos
patients et je reviendrai peut-être sur
vos dernières questions rapidement sur
le suicide
oui on a des quelques chiffres chez les
médecins chez les vétérinaires mais très
peu en fait et ça c'est dommage par
contre on sait que la prévalence chez
les femmes pour les tentatives de
suicide et deux fois plus importante que
chez les hommes et ça a toute population
confondues alors que les suicides chez
les hommes sont plus importants que chez
donc 200 000 tentatives de suicide en
France
un suicide tous les heures en France
voilà et trois professionnels de la
santé qui suscitent tous les deux jours
ça montre la gravité et nous on les a
tous les jours on a les familles
derrière c'est pour ça que j'en parle
parce qu'il y a urgence aussi agir il y
a urgence d'en parler pas seulement avec
une ligne 31 14 qui a 70% de taux
décrochés mais avec des plateformes
efficaces qui répondent et qui prennent
en urgence ces personnes en tout cas
nous on agit vraiment au niveau des
soignants et des soignants sur ce sujet
je vais essayer de faire très rapide vu
de la vue de la contrainte horaire sur
la première question qui est celle de du
changement de carrière professionnelle
alors je vais pas pouvoir étayer
[Musique]
plus que ça les propos je pense qu'il y
a d'autres organisations qui seront plus
à même de le faire les ordres notamment
qui peuvent avoir une vision sur
l'installation ou le parcours
professionnel au sein de la profession
et puis Pôle emploi ou des organismes
tels que tels que Pôle emploi qui
peuvent vous aurez enfin avoir une
incidence sur quel est le changement de
métier vers lequel se dirige les
professionnels nous en tout cas on sait
qu'elles ont une volonté de changer
de la combien on passe le pas le taux de
rotation des effectifs de la fonction
publique hospitaire je crois des 8 et
des à peu près 8% avec beaucoup de plus
en plus de contractuels donc il y a un
vrai sujet mais j'ai pas la donnée soit
les incivilités alors effectivement on a
pris un panel représentatif des actifs
en emploi donc mécaniquement dedans il y
a pas que des personnes qui sont
concernées par l'exposition du public il
n'empêche qu'on n'a pas interrogé que
sur les violences auxquelles on s'expose
du fait du public
c'est les violences du fait du public
mais aussi les violences au sein du
travail et on sait que les violences que
subissent les soignants ne sont pas
uniquement que des violences
issues des patients il y a aussi une
violence inhérente au métier avec qui
vous êtes enfin pour lequel vous êtes
confrontés au quotidien des difficultés
sociales à la mort
enfin à la tristesse des émotions
tristes et des situations compliquées
donc il y a un vrai sujet et donc cette
violence elle est au globale sur les
dépistages je vous suis effectivement il
y a une offre une possibilité d'avoir
recours en interne à lui dépistage la
question et c'est la même pour la santé
psychologique qui a soulevé Catherine
tout à l'heure est-ce qu'un soignant
veut se faire diagnostiquer de son
cancer par le praticien avec qui est des
jeunes tous les jours au self c'est idem
sur la médecine du travail c'est idem
sur le soutien psychologique est-ce
qu'on veut démontrer sa pathologie sur
le sujet et ensuite enfin sur son lieu
de travail donc il y a un vrai sujet de
coordination et puis par ailleurs cet
accès direct à du dispositif qui vous
permet de faire du diagnostic il est
très inégal dans la fonction publique
hospitalière il y a 20% des effectifs
qui travaillent en structure
médico-sociale
il y a pas de plateau technique donc il
y a un sujet d'accessibilité globale aux
campagnes de dépistage et enfin je
terminerai mon propos là-dessus sur une
réaction que vous avez eu madame la
rapporteur Rossignol sur le sur la
question de la charge mentale on a un
vrai sujet à traiter sur la charge
mentale y compris des femmes en santé
qui est dans le cadre de l'équilibre vie
personnelle vie professionnelle un vrai
sujet de préoccupation qui a un sujet
sociétal mais sur lequel on a une focale
en santé avec 80% de femmes qui ont à
supporter en plus de la charge
professionnelle une charge mentale très
forte
issue d'un historique qu'on connaît et
qu'on n'aura pas traité aujourd'hui vu
le temps qui nous est imparti
et bien écoutez merci à vous trois pour
vos propos vos explications vos
démonstrations merci à mesdames les
rapporteurs nous avons eu cette table
ronde qui nous permettait quand même de
faire un tour de table intéressant sur
les métiers du Caire et de la santé des
femmes au travail donc n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer d'autres éléments si vous
estimez ne pas avoir eu par exemple
suffisamment de temps pour répondre aux
questions de nos rapporteurs je vous
remercie et je vous souhaite à tous et à
toutes une belle journée merci beaucoup
au revoir à bientôt au revoir